ever since 2014 Steven universe slowly
became one of the most talked about
shows on Cartoon Network but the
mysterious show comes with lots of facts
you might or might not already know stay
tuned to see which amazing celebrity
actually got to play one of the
characters don't forget to give this
video a thumbs up and subscribe to the
things now let's check out ten secret
Steven universe facts Cartoon Network
doesn't want you to know too many
secrets okay let's start with a secret
that hasn't been revealed just quite yet
fans are speculating that there are far
more secrets behind the gem home world
than the show revealed so far Rebecca
sugar the creator behind Steven universe
said the gem world is definitely full of
secrets that not even Steven knows about
we always see things from Steven's
perspective and very rarely do we get a
look at what the gems are doing
individually what do you think the gems
are hiding some fans seem to suspect
that the gems are actually the
antagonists of the story and that in the
future they will all turn against Steven
but we truly hope that this is just a
theory that will never come true when
Rebecca did and asked me anything thread
on reddit she made fans think that some
of the crystal gems as well as the
others were directly responsible for the
corruption of the world as we know it in
the show it's also interesting that some
fans pointed out the gems originally
wanted to harm the planet more than they
wanted to harm the humanity but fans
have a feeling that there's definitely a
backstory that's not being shared with
Steven or any of us it's a secret of an
unexplained secret stages of human
emotional development here's an
interesting one when Rebecca sugar did
her asked me anything thread on reddit
she received a question theory that she
actually confirmed as the truth I
redditor pointed out that the Steven
universe characters perfectly fit in the
five stages of human development theory
they said that steven is the codependent
while amethyst is the counter dependent
Explorer and a rebel that wants to fight
the authority even if it's a bad idea
and then there's pearl who's the group
dependent and always responsible to the
point where it's sometimes it doesn't
even make sense and
there's garnet who's the independent a
bit reckless but takes on the burdens of
others without much thought in a weird
twist
Rebecca confirmed that this is exactly
what she was going for when she first
created these characters and the human
development theory is what partially
brought them to life it definitely makes
sense because we can still relate to the
characters even though their looks and
their story doesn't fit the typical
relatable story line interestingly
enough the fifth stage of the human
development theory is called
transcendence which is all about
controlling your emotions and learning
how to be empathetic and understanding
of things around them it's interesting
that Rebecca thinks none of the
characters yet fit in that stage based
on real life speaking of highlighted
personalities that relate to Universal
theories of human development did you
know that the characters are based on
real-life characters well sort of
Stephen sugar is actually Rebecca sugars
brother and that's who's actually
featured as the main character of the
story so Stephen is based on real life
but what about other characters it's
hard to believe someone like amethyst
who actually exists
right well sort of the gems are actually
based off of how Rebecca behaves around
her brother sometimes she's extremely
protective other times she is more
rebellious like amethyst so in a way
Steven universe represents the typical
brother-sister relationship many
siblings get to share of course those
siblings don't have superpowers but it's
just another layer to show and an
explanation why many people find Steven
universe so fascinating Steven sugar is
also the background designer of the show
he actually drew a few versions of
himself on Twitter and you can
definitely see the resemblance between
him as an adult and Steven and Steven
universe that's pretty cool to be honest
lesson learned if you're nice to your
siblings you might be an inspiration
behind some of the coolest stories ever
criticism Steven universe actually faced
a lot of criticism from people that just
couldn't get onboard the crystal gems
train
Steven universe is often praised for its
inclusion of a non-binary gender but
there are plenty of people that gave
several reasons as to why they dislike
the show including this there
three page Google Doc sa that goes into
great detail and explains why this show
has failed while of course every cartoon
has its flaws
this writer known as a model ami
presented this as an interesting manner
some of the things he mentioned included
the character development like amethyst
for example who is suddenly revealed to
have a troubled past without much
backdrop he goes on to say that
characters are allowed to be flawed but
it makes much more sense if those flaws
are established properly another Steven
universe critique touches on the racial
issue as the first 10 episodes dismissed
garnet and overall stereotype her entire
look as a black character the behavior
around garnet raised a lot of eyebrows
considering she was also often
manipulated in order to consent to
certain situations what do you think is
garnets character treated unfairly or is
it just a matter of coincidence
since Steven universe fans claim the
characters have no race or no gender let
us know frustrated fans in 2017 fans
have started noticing that the ratings
have started to drop which launched
plenty of conspiracy theories we'll talk
more about what Dan's think of Cartoon
Network in general but first let's look
at some secret facts that Cartoon
Network doesn't want you to know unless
you look for it you wouldn't know this
but Steven universe ratings have
plummeted and it's all due to its
incredibly frustrating schedule although
a lot of fans do stream the show and
watch it online there are plenty that
still tune in to the Cartoon Network
channel to watch their favorite show
when Cartoon Network announced a two
season renewal in 2016 the reactions
were mixed people were happy but they
also complained because at that time
Cartoon Network was still releasing
season three even though the fans knew
it was completed because spoilers of the
season were leaked before it officially
came out even though the show is still
going strong it also had several long
hiatuses that made the fans incredibly
worried Cartoon Network has a long
history of terrible scheduling
inconsistencies and it doesn't matter
whether the show holds a large audience
for now Steven universe remains safe but
knowing the history behind Cartoon
Network shows is that really the case
the comics speaking of Steven universe
unless you're a huge fan you probably
don't know that Rebecca sugar also
created Steven universe comics there
like comics that have been coming out
since 2014 the stories usually still
follow the characters and present a bit
more information on them and several
what-if situations however not everyone
is happy with these comic books it's
true that Rebecca sugar said that comic
books are the best way to creatively
express yourself before you dive into
animation but Steven universe fans just
aren't impressed they have pointed out
the comics are much more simplified and
carefully outline to make sure they
don't include anything that could
possibly lead to future contradictions
in the main story but according to the
band Stephen and the gang don't really
do much in these comics anyways there's
no extra backstory information instead
they just focus on adding just a tiny
bit of flavor to the original story
without ruining or spoiling anything in
advance simple storylines in the comic
books don't sit well with those that may
have way too many questions about
crystal gems because let's be honest a
lot of those questions are still
unanswered so it looks like we won't get
the answers from comic books Sailor Moon
here's an interesting fact did you know
that Rebecca sugar has a hidden secret
not many people have known but it
actually connects to Steven universe
well it's sort of a hidden secret but
fans of the show have actually compared
Rebecca sugars look to the cute
animation character from Sailor Moon and
know they're not the same person but for
some strange reason Steven universe
still pays homage to Sailor Moon the
show features plenty of popular culture
references and we can even see that
Steven has some Sailor Moon manga in his
room you can also notice several moments
the Steven universe characters do that
are almost identical to the movement of
Sailor moons characters fans of the show
are always looking for new references to
Sailor Moon it's unclear whether Rebecca
sugar is actually just paying homage to
an anime she loves or if there are any
other secret connections between the two
shows we'll definitely be keeping an eye
on this one as we can really see more of
Sailor Moon in Steven universe but we're
still not over just how much the
animation character resembles Rebecca do
you think it's all just a bit of
coincidence or disre baka really have a
doppelganger Novak stories here's
another fact as of March 2018 Steven
universe hasn't really had a lot of
backstories of certain characters
everyone wants to know more about in
fact the entire fifth season never
really focused on amethyst so far we
know that amethyst is out of control and
she loves to be a rebel although she
acts tough she indulges in a lot of
self-loathing and we all know that she
has a troubled past
but the past was never really explained
properly and people have so many
questions everyone wants to know more
about amethyst shape-shifting and why
she ended up the way she did apart from
amethyst we also had never seen Pearl's
backstory either it's not yet clear who
pearl belongs to or why she can never
really talk about her past
since the storyline has a strong fantasy
vibe it allows Rebecca sugar to really
play around with possible new plots but
that only leaves the fans feeling
frustrated since there are so many
Steven universe questions people would
just love to have answers - do you mind
that the show went on for so long but
there are still hardly any backstories
given on these complex characters if you
could ask Rebecca sugar one question
what would it be let us know in the
comments unhealthy relationships one of
the few surprising elements this show
does really well is exploring unhealthy
relationships and teaching teens and
adults to watch the show and how to
resolve them will focus on lapis and
Jasper's relationship which was also
brought up by Rebecca sugar herself she
said that she had never really seen a
cartoon do this but she wanted to
express a story that was very much real
in people's lives and it was important
to address it lapis and Jasper are in a
complicated relationship in which laugh
has spelt like she had no control which
caused her to be angry and she really
was angry and led out all of her anger
on Jasper and Rebecca points out that
she was so angry it didn't even matter
who her anger was aimed at but then her
anger disappeared once they separated
and in a predictable turn of events
Jasper knows exactly what to do to win
her back lapis goes into this
self-destructive state which is often
what the actual victims of unhealthy
relationships do there's also of course
the case of Jasper forcing diffused with
lapis when she
doesn't want to overall this is an
extremely important highlight of an
unhealthy relationship and it's just one
of the things this show does extremely
well Nicki Minaj we bet not even all
Nicki Minaj fans know this fact and it
definitely wasn't promoted enough but
Nicki Minaj did actually appear in
Steven universe this was back in 2014
and although she was only featured for
one episode it definitely should have
been talked about more how and why it
happened no one actually knows but
Rebecca sugar stated she absolutely
loved working with Nicki Nicki appeared
as the character called sugilite which
is an amazing fusion between amethyst
and garnet of course we all know they
would fuse into something totally epic
but did anyone expect Nicki Minaj to
voice that character we definitely
didn't sugilite appeared in two episodes
although she was only speaking in one of
them even though we probably won't ever
see sugilite again since we all know
Nicki's expensive it was just really
cool to see Nicki in such a crazy
cartoon and in a character that has a
larger-than-life personality just like
she does speaking of we'd absolutely
love an animated version of Nicki Minaj
Nikki hasn't addressed the Steven
universe episode just yet but we have a
feeling she definitely enjoyed playing
the independent suji lights the question
is will we see more of suji light or was
that just a one-of-a-kind addition to
this crazy but an amazing show we'll
have to stay tuned to find out and
that's all for our video don't forget to
subscribe to the things and tell us how
you felt about this video thanks for
watching see you next time
[Music]